that's so embarrassing it's the most
it's literally one of the most
embarrassing things that can ever happen
to a human being
[Laughter]
[Music]
mission 1 k
so we are trying to obviously quit our
jobs gang
and we want to give you guys as much
content as possible
content content man's ad-libbing
content content the only way we can do
that is if
well the starting point is if we hit a
thousand
pounds on patreon a month we will be
able to minimize the hours we do at work
so we can contribute more time to what
we love
and produce two episodes a week we are
on track with that
so just guys please help us out if you
love what we do and if you love
listening to us or watching us however
you prefer to
get our stuff contribute man and then
at the end of the day it benefits you
guys in the future so yeah man that's
the that's the mission 1k and when we do
hit that mission 1k
trust me it's only going to get better
from there bro
it's only going to get better from there
once mission 1k
has been successfully completed
the thing's gonna pop the thing's gonna
pop absolutely pop it's gonna pop so
yeah man hit us up on our patreon all
links in the bio
click that and then select whichever
tier you want any contribution will be
much really appreciated so yeah man cool
man let's get the ball rolling let's go
um let's go do you have any edge in
business
um i never have urgent business i just
have business just talk about it
it's never urgent um do you ever
sometimes think
he's just done his he's just done his
monster ting gone
do you sometimes ever think that it's
mad that we've got a voice in our head
and no one questions it
yes like you can i can say stuff in my
head now
and it is my voice and it just no no one
question it's just it's just
accepted that we've got a voice in our
head like our mind is thinking for us
but we can hear ourselves think
don't you think that's crazy yeah like
do i sometimes think like
is my voice is what you're hearing in
your head
what you hit with now what in my head in
my head
my voice is my voice yes and i'm
speaking as i would speak
yes but am i actually speaking
in my head do you know what i mean yes
because obviously in order for me to
speak i have to form a sentence yes but
that's not how your brain works
yes your brain just scrambles
information and you understand it
because it's your brain
so i'm thinking the voice in my head is
that actually a voice
because is it actually trying to form
sentences like is it actually trying to
make
coherent words that i can understand or
does it just
shoot information and i interpret it as
as a sentence or as words like
is it actually a voice because i don't
ever really sit when you have the voice
in your head
it doesn't obviously take as long to
process a thought yeah
it doesn't take as long as it would for
me to say in a sentence yeah because
they're two different things yeah it
must not be speaking the way i think it
is
but it's the only way i how i understand
processing information so i just
interpret it as a voice
that's crazy a stoner chat in it that is
stoner yeah i thought about it when i
was done
there's so many it's true there's so
many things i write down when i'm stolen
that makes sense to me when i'm stoned
but i feel like some people may or may
not think about it but when i say it's
like ah
i would never thought about that yeah do
you know what i mean that's the reason
why right now yeah
that's the reason i hate you bro it's
it's weird to me sometimes
i've got another one go like when i was
in a shower this was about
a few weeks ago i was in a shower and i
was thinking don't you just think it's
weird
weird that your skeleton just keeps you
up like it just
it does what it needs to do do you know
what i mean your skeleton just does what
it needs to do because
your body can never take a day off oh
yeah like imagine your heart stopped for
a second you'd be on the [ __ ] floor
yeah bro it from from the word girl from
when you're born you're
your body's going yeah it's not taking a
day off since you were in your mom's
womb
yep and that's mind-blowing because it
sometimes makes me think [ __ ] people
are not people but i've taken my body
for granted sometimes
and it's not like that's not what i'm
trying to preach like don't take it but
forgot but it's just
a good realization to have that your
body works
20 even when you're sleeping your body's
working twenty years doing bits all the
time
all day every your body can't have a day
your heart's knocking
it's been knackered
as soon as you're born it's counting
down the days until it stops
bro and in order to make it better
you have to run and [ __ ] you have to you
have to exercise it and make it work
even harder and harder it's a big man
just leave me as the [ __ ] alone
it's hard enough it's not enough when
you're laying on your [ __ ] back
stop running up hills and [ __ ] just let
me let me live
let me chill for 10 minutes ah there's
something that's why when your heart
stops it's not coming back it's
because it's tired your heart's been
tight this is done your heart is done
that's what has to get electricity
involved he wants his chinese fun
it doesn't work he doesn't want to
revive
himself for what for who
who are you he treats me like [ __ ] it
seems to me like [ __ ] [ __ ]
why would i why would i be again you
know i i had a stoner
i've actually got i never come up with
good stone to chat but i've got a cool
stoner chat one
don't you think this is actually quite
relevant even though i thought about it
before the pandemic
yes um it's actually quite relevant
um now that everyone has to wear masks
and [ __ ] yeah is that
don't you think it's crazy that you
recognize people purely by their face
yeah like i can know you yeah i can
know you yeah and if you go like that i
have no idea who you are
you know you know like obviously when
you're um playing with a baby
yeah and you're like peekaboo and
they're like then oh
wait yeah yeah yeah and you're like i'm
here and they're like
okay you're here you're here that's what
you dipped
it i thought you bounced and then you
just like that and you're like
how [ __ ] stupid are babies yeah these
times
you could know my faith you could know
everything about me you know my height
you know what i look like you know my
hair cut you know my beard you know
everything
and then as soon as i'm like that you're
like who's that is it him
that's a stranger yeah as soon as i put
a mask on i'm a stranger
i'm a [ __ ] you have no idea who i am
that's a bit wild
isn't that wild that's a bit wild like
even to my mum like if my mom had just a
mask on
if like a like a full face mask i have
no idea who that is
i've seen her forever my entire life
i've seen my mom but all she has to do
is that
and i have no idea who it is that's your
point of reference for you
for everyone for everyone do you think
they're so like archaic it is this this
thing
this thing is the only way people can
identify me it's crazy you said that
because i was
it's another stoner chat i was saying
like
i apart from mirrors i actually like
what you're looking at me now i don't
know what i look like
same i do not know what i look like so
my only blind spot
is my actual face on the back of my head
do you not think that's crazy like
that's the only blind spot you have like
there are times when i'm talking to
people and they're looking at me and i'm
looking at them
and i actually don't know what i look
like to them
and they don't know what they look like
to themselves but they see themselves
all the time in the mirror and i see
myself but i've never looked at myself
before fam i've never actually seen
myself before that's how i felt the
first time i ever saw
a video recording of myself back in
school
first time i ever actually saw like a
long-standing video recording of me
speaking just being normal yeah i was
thinking [ __ ] that's what everyone sees
this is what everyone sees and it's not
what i see in the mirror it's not
it's actually not what i see in the
mirror it's wild
especially like when you're especially
when you do some dumb stuff and you
think to yourself you look cool and when
you're dancing
like you don't know what you actually
look like it's true because there's
definitely i'd say there's definitely a
disconnect
when i'm editing or if i'm just watching
an episode or something there's
definitely a disconnect that doesn't
make it feel like that's me
do you know what i mean i know what you
mean because there's something about it
that doesn't look like me i know what
you mean
it's not who i see in the mirror ever
something about it that doesn't look
like me
there's something that's right because
in i think in
there's no the mirrors we have aren't
true mirrors it's not a true reflection
because it re
it reverses yeah yeah how you look at
yourself yeah i know what you mean so
there's there's only
a few true reflection mirrors like you
have to buy it from like exclusive
places and stuff so
i've seen it on tick tock somewhere yeah
it's actually a thing it's a thing yeah
i've seen it
and i've seen someone look at themselves
in a tik tok video and it looks weird
because obviously i see him
on tiktok i've seen his face but when he
shows him his self
in a true reflection thing it looks so
weird it looks so weird i need to google
this
it looks so weird that sounds weird
because a lot of the time as well your
face is symmetrical like one half of
your face
is like maybe like droopier than the
other and i know i've seen mine
have you see have you seen that that's
on tv because i've seen that
i've seen that because the people look
off when they do the double magical
thing the symmetrical person is
banging and then when they change and
then they're even like they look like
quasimodo
[Music]
they look [ __ ] but that's what they
normally look like that's what they
normally look like it's weird bro
it's weird and that's actually crazy
because they've always said like
attraction is about symmetry
i've grown up i've heard that a million
times some people say ah you're
attracted the most attractive people are
the most symmetrical
faces and you're just like yeah okay
whatever you don't really think about it
but then as soon as i saw that thing on
tiktok i was like
that person's banging and then they do
that and just
it looks like their face caves in and
you're like [ __ ] hell it's weird
wow it is about symmetry it's all about
symmetra and you never know what you
look like
don't know what you don't you don't even
know what you look like because i
literally don't know why i look like
saying this to you right now that's why
i get
i've always had that on like um dates
and [ __ ] any moment i've ever had of
sexual
tension before it gets too heated and i
don't give a [ __ ] about what i look like
yeah but the beginnings of sexual
tension and eye contact i always think
what do i look like what do i look like
am i am i portraying sexy enough
stupidity if i'm smiling or something
and i'm just there like
and i don't know she's thinking yuck
yuck this guy's actually not piff
it's crazy bro do you ever slightly
different do you ever like
have that moment like you're with
someone yeah and you've been staring at
each other like you've been close it
could be a date or it could just be like
you had to [ __ ] or whatever yeah and you
go to the toilet
yeah and it's not a big deal but you've
got something
like a bit of dry skin on your nose or a
little something here
and you're thinking she's seen that the
whole time i know she has i've got to
tell you a story so
this was tight i'm gonna have the
giggles today just born in i can tell
i'm gonna have the giggles
go this was way before i moved to money
um so
i wasn't even seeing this chick but like
we used to flirt and stuff
you know who it is you'll probably guess
it anyway okay
um i won't give you like the ins and out
of her but
long story short we were seeing it we
were like we had a ting basically
we had a flight we never [ __ ] but we
had a thing there's a time ago you
wouldn't know
um and there's one time i never knew she
was going to list me because she was
kind of seeing she was seeing someone
but we were flirting
we were flirting all day every day all
the time
all the time and there's one time we
shared because she lived
we lived in the same direction on the
way home but she lived about 15 minutes
closer than i did so we sometimes would
share a taxi home drop her arm first and
then i go
but there's one time i we shared a taxi
um
which obviously dropped her in first but
she had to get out
on my side so i get out first to get her
out so when i got out first obviously
the tension was already high but i
wasn't in the position i
i didn't want to do anything purely
because i already knew
her situation so i didn't want to be the
one to make any step because
it's not my place so when i got out
she got out she just turned around and
lips to me
absolutely lips to me and it was the
first time you had ever lips i was like
and because prior to that we had been
[ __ ] we had been flying sounds so buff
she lips i was like oh
so now i know it's on do you know what i
mean okay so that that was done
fast forward i don't know how long later
probably a couple of moms probably not
um i went to hers after work or
something
we went we didn't have sex or anything
but we were about it we were
busy we were busy and this was late at
night so
no i had dropped her home obviously she
invited me up we were doing whatever
didn't [ __ ] um but
it was not until i went to so
remember you said about the spec on your
face thing it's not until i had gotten
left has got into the elevator
that her no mascara her foundation
makeup was
all over my face
and she's been seeing this even when i
left the yard she didn't even be like yo
did you give me like a kiss goodbye and
something did you probably i can't
remember and she just let you leave she
just let me
leave with all of this on my face
and you're you're gassed i'm obviously
gasps because i feel like i've done the
most and obviously when you said like
the sexual
face and stuff i'm doing the most i'm
doing this
licking lips everything and your whole
face is white giving i'm giving her the
seduction eyes
and my face is just plastered with
foundation
plastered and when i got to the elevator
i gasped luckily it was dick in the
clock
and no one saw me from leaving her yard
to get into the elevator to get into the
elevator to get into my car
fam as soon as i got hot because
obviously with foundation one obviously
but
when you when you've got foundation on
your face you can't just wipe it off
you can't face a face you're scrubbing
it rub your face and it's not coming out
oh my god
so as soon as i got home i just
found that's if anyone saw me in the
lift i was so embarrassed that i saw
myself
it's the one of the most embarrassing
things that i've seen and i was the only
one there i could imagine
i could [ __ ] imagine bro i can
imagine
because she didn't say a word she didn't
say a word it blew my mind and i don't
understand why
i think she felt like if she did she may
have felt embarrassed
but i'm 10 times more embarrassed and
she probably felt like
if you if she said it you'd and you saw
yourself
you'll be thinking how much [ __ ]
makeup does this go where maybe
like how much [ __ ] makeup does that
could have been over me that could have
been
one of my thought processes when i saw
myself yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah but that wasn't my immediate
thought yeah
yeah so maybe maybe that's why she
didn't tell me if i'm [ __ ] like that
being dark-skinned and liking white
girls
is a danger i've seen man i wanna i've
seen one of our friends
lip-sitting in a club turned to me
and his face is white enough how i've
held from my stomach
from my guts fab guts you know when you
can't get the laugh out enough yeah
and i was just screaming and he was so
happy
that's the best because he didn't know
he didn't i don't know so man just
lipstick turned to me and he's smiling
family
i was [ __ ] howling that's so
embarrassing
it's the most it's literally one of the
most embarrassing things that can ever
happen to a human being
[Laughter]
what i would have given to see you what
i would have given you to see you walk
out the apartment building to your car
or whatever
and then just be a passerby and clock
your face right
you know when you come outside and you
give the the right left look
jackie's on you get a rider like if i
was walking past and i saw you leaving
so it looks like you're leaving a yacht
or something and you've just got
foundation all over your face i would
drop to my knees and after
you'd want to fight me because you don't
know me like that i would drop to my
knees in laughter
knees funny that's like
is that the guy's version of the walk of
shame 100 it's the guy's version of the
walking dead because like when i go to
the walking shame you
know she got [ __ ] last night yeah and
when a guy comes out with a foundation
all over his face
you know he's been with a ticket he's
been there no denying that
there's nothing you can deny to anyone
he's just busy
he's been busy he's been busy with a
nice white girl
it's the funniest [ __ ] it's so funny oh
i'm sorry you're so embarrassed i've
never had to go through that but i'm
sorry you went through it
because it's my fear no one caught me so
that was the saving grace but it
made me realize i think that was the
first time i'd realized i need to calm
down
in terms of if i'm listening or
whitening or doing anything with a white
girl
just be careful yes it's gonna show yes
you know what i mean yes especially if
i'm not at my yard
yes yes just be careful bro so that that
opened my eye and this was time ago is
that open
i know who it is now and it was time ago
i know exactly who it is that's fine
that's [ __ ] funny bro it was it was
the most embarrassed when i saw myself
in a
in the lift because he had obviously
mirrors and stuff my heart could have
left my chest i
ghast bro i look like a masquerade it
was
it felt like someone just plastered
chalk all over my face with jokes
it was [ __ ] it was embarrassing but it
was fun that's funny it was funny
i was thinking of something the other
day unrelated
the new like dm game
is so peak in terms of
the passive aggressive combo enders
like liking my message yes it's the most
passive aggressive [ __ ] you can do
because it's done you might as well tell
me [ __ ] off now
you might as well tap your watch and say
time's up
when you like my message and don't res
and that's it fun
if i'm already because the peak thing is
obviously if i'm on instagram
and then the notification will come up
is that da da like your message
if i don't if i click my dms now and i
see
liked message in the bold black and i'm
waiting
and i said it better say typing in four
seconds
in the next four seconds it better say
typing cause uh
because if you've just double tapped and
left it you've basically told me to
[ __ ] off it's done it's time to [ __ ] off
and then if
if either message again double up i'm a
waste man double
i think i've ever had was maybe i can't
remember if it was a guy or a girl or
what
liked message so message message back
and forth back and forth it must have
been a go at something i can't remember
back and forth back and forth back and
forth
call call call call double tap she
double tap me
and i was like cool left it a minute no
response
and then something something um i can't
remember something that we were talking
about
previously so not where we left the
convert but something
that we were talking about previously
related to something i was watching on
tv or something
okay so i was like oh cool winky dink
this this this
so i ended up messaging twice okay so
she's double tapped me
i've messaged again about something that
was funny that we'll talk about earlier
and she hit me with the lol lowercase
their first l wasn't even caps she
wanted to
imprint it lol lower case
[ __ ] off she's basically this she chewed
you away
fam i was mortified i was mortified
because it
my pride my pride and it's
the way i say is passive aggressive
there's nothing i can say yeah yeah
there's nothing i can say
i can't be like you're [ __ ] rude
because i can't be like you're rude
because she hasn't done anything rude
but the double tap
and the lowercase lol is so harsh
but it's essential because i don't get
me wrong i do all the [ __ ] time well
you need to get the combo done you need
to find a way to pattern it without
sounding rude fam
if you're laughing like the lol game has
changed as well yeah if i said something
funny
and you give and it ain't all caps or it
ain't emojis
if it's if it's just a standard lol
fight me
fight me because clearly you want this
conversation done but you want the
conversation done you didn't actually
find it funny
you didn't that's embarrassing i want
all caps bettos
when i'm hitting you with the spice
emojis if you just put one laughing face
that's also rude
because it's not that funny it's not as
funny as you thought it was
i thought i was going in and i got the
one laughing face i thought you were
kevin hart
i want lines of laughing faces in fact i
want an
a capital l laughing face stuff
that's how you know you've hit the
premium laugh the premium laugh i know
what you mean firm
there's so different so many different
types of other world that would
make or break you make or break you
yeah yep yeah yeah yeah it changes it
changes the whole game and it
does it changes the whole game and the
dm is
and a double message is just desperate
in peak i know but
you're an advocate for a double message
when you need it when you need that's
what's gonna say when you need it
because
sometimes what maybe what i've said
has not you've got nothing more to say
about it yeah so if she likes it maybe
she's trying to
still instigate something you're a
wishful thinker but you know what i mean
you're not even not even a wish
you're an optimist optimist i'm more of
an optimist yeah
i'm like
i don't know that you like me until i've
butternut
inside you so i'm
not such a pessimist nothing sir i'm
such a pessimist so if you've double
tapped me
i'm gone and i will even delete the
convo
to make sure that i don't double message
you oh my god i'm going to forget this
i'm such a pessimist thus if you double
tap me
or a lowercase lol
done that's me i have to get rid of it
because if i like you i'll message you
again
and then as soon as i've sent it this
reminds me this reminds me this reminds
me of
me do you remember times
where you've sent well you said a risque
text or a risque message so you're
flirting like it's light flirts
okay and you're either trying to pattern
a bang
or a nude or such a sign yeah and you've
sent a risque
text and so she's like you've done a
quick back and forth yeah kind of like
it kind of flirty kind of flirty
and the opportunity strikes well you can
take it to level two
yeah defcon 2. yeah yeah and you're like
you type it you maybe edit it a little
bit to make it you proof
read the whole thing the whole thing and
you're like has to make sense this
is my dissertation like this is it this
is it
you're turning it in you send it and
you're hot racing you're like cool cool
cool
cool cool then it pops up scene and
there's like a four minute gap
and you are like oh my god and you just
you oh my god oh my god i won
and you're you're fighting with yourself
whether to text again
and be like i'm joking or what it's like
inside and you
lock the phone and you dash it you look
just launch it family you're swearing
sweating it's the worst feeling it's the
worst feeling i've fallen prey
to the haha just kidding so many times
and i'm so angry at myself fam when i've
said a risque message
if it's early on i don't know this girl
okay
if i don't know this girl yeah and i've
sent a risky satin
and she and she's seen it and ain't
replied straight away
fam i try to hold it with my chest
these days obviously i'd be much better
but this is time ago i'm talking about
okay i didn't really give a [ __ ] anymore
back these times fam i would panic mode
and i'd be like oh don't say you're
joking come on firm if i'm if i'm it
don't say it's a joke don't say it's a
joke you know it's not joke she knows
it's not a joke
don't [ __ ] out because as soon as you
say you're kidding brother it's done
it's done
it's done you can't bring that up again
you can't bring it in you can't accept
yeah
you can't you can't and you're the
prankster now you're not you're not a
man to her
you know what i'm saying you're not a
man you're a boy you're a comedian
you're not a man to this girl oh he's
gonna make me laugh today
yeah yeah and like realistically she
might think
he's taking the piss a bit or she might
be thinking [ __ ] it let me give him a
little something something
you get me and the amount of times i've
just been like
kidding i've never done that and i've
done it one time i've done it one time
where i've sent it and as i've prescend
to say as i've presented ha ha kidding
she's responded in the perfect way
and i f [ __ ] it i have [ __ ] i would
have deleted that
kid in with such swiftness i don't think
you understand bro i
[ __ ] it
and i'm because because the four minutes
to you seems like eternity
it feels like seven hours it feels like
he turned i feel like she's
blocked me it feels like
ages oh but do you know the one turn off
about like when you're
flirting with someone back and forth
someone new
grammar grammar is
the biggest if you can't text properly
you can't form a sentence properly yeah
if you don't you don't have to proofread
but like
if you're talking to someone you're
trying to impress them regardless yes
regardless you're trying to bring the
best version of
yourself yeah yeah so if you're just if
your sentences don't make sense if
you're making stupid
spelling mistakes like if i'm talking to
a chick obviously i'm 29.
so if i'm talking to chicks she's going
to be of a certain age where she
knows how to spell words do you know
what i mean she's not an idiot yep
so when uh things like that drive me and
say and it's not just guys because i
know a girl this is time ago
i know girl that went to our uni she was
seeing someone i knew from ends for
i wouldn't say see it but they had a
quick a few things back and forth i
don't even know if they had sex or
anything but they saw each other
but she showed because i knew he made
bad mistakes because obviously when i
when i used to text him yeah yeah yeah
i'm thinking do you do you not see what
you write yeah yeah yeah you know what i
mean
do you not see what you're writing yeah
yeah so there are times where me and her
used to link up and chill like because
we're friends we're not not like that
but we'd link up and chill and whatever
and she'd show me some of the messages
he had sent her
and i'm just thinking i get it i get why
you're turned off
because it's it's the biggest turn off
and i don't understand because it says a
lot about you
it does it says so much about you it
actually does
unfortunately unfortunately i'm watching
actually in my opinion anyway it might
not
some people might not give a [ __ ] but
for me i don't know what it is about
like it's it's like like you say it's a
representation of yourself if you don't
give a [ __ ] on
making grammatical errors and stuff or
like
spelling mistakes and blah blah then you
just don't care about so much it's true
you don't care about so much
bro it's true it's such eternal so lazy
it's so lazy
lazy especially if it's a new thing
especially if it's a new thing
because they're just gonna think i'm
stupid if i'm making these dumb areas
they're gonna think i'm stupid bro
yes do you know what's also a turn off
for me is like when i
when i try because i like grammar
i like being linguistical i know what
you mean yeah
when i use a word that is
okay not hard not hard
and not even a massive word but like
she just won't understand what it means
and not only will she not understand
she hasn't even got the balls to google
it she's not even the balls the sense
the common sense says to google it
she'll ask me what's that mean
and i'm just like how do you don't know
i've got a perfect example
perfect example got one so i was talking
to a chick before this was time ago as
well
um and you know me i'm always hungry i
love to eat yes i love to eat yes so she
would ask me your house today what are
you doing
and i said i'm [ __ ] ravenous babes
and she like what the [ __ ] does ravenous
mean
wow and i'm thinking ravenness is basic
ravenous is basic that's english that's
a basic similarity that's as basic as it
gets
basic i'm thinking how did you i knew
that when i was six
i really did even if you don't know what
it means just google it
just don't ask me the thing is it's not
like you said it i'm not saying she
doesn't
have to spell it we're not face to face
she can see the word
[ __ ] google it i would google it even
when people use
short um what's that i don't know what
you mean acronyms
acronyms even when people use short
acronyms to me i'll google it if i don't
understand this
there's one acronym that took me time to
get i had one which one um
i y k
i y k y k it's all over twitter
and i'm thinking what the [ __ ] oh if you
know you know i didn't know that for
time i didn't know that fourth time
there's one
it blew my mind i can't remember which
one it is but there was one that stumped
me for
[ __ ] ages this is embarrassing do you
know what one actually did obviously
years and years ago do you know what
stumped me for ages
do you know what stopped me for ages
goats
no goat stop me for time do you know why
because people started putting the
[ __ ] goat emoji next to it
and i was like he's the goat with the
goat emoji and i'm like what this
go go
i get it i don't get it what's this
gold thing oh that's fine i thought it
was like a
trend thing so you know how like the
trend right now is like cake
everything's made of cake yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so obviously when
people are talking cake that's not an
acronym
they're talking about actual cake yeah i
thought it was one of them things and
i'm like what is this goat thing about
like is there a goat meme that i just
haven't been saying yeah yeah but it
went on for
[ __ ] weeks
weeks and i can't remember how i sussed
it that's hilarious i either sussed it
just all by myself or i googled it or
whatever
and once i started i was like i want to
kill myself
it made so much sense sam
and it was so basic and easy and i was
just like oh
[ __ ] you know you do fall prey to it
sometimes sometimes you just do
sometimes you literally it's not you
know you no one stumps me i can imagine
that yeah yeah
for weeks i don't think for weeks james
infuriated me yeah infuriated me what
was the other one i got me
i can't remember there's a really basic
one that got me for ages so i can't
remember what it was
i think that's the only one that's ever
gotten me guarded me everything else i'm
kind of gauged yeah i can usually suss
it in about like
like what you just did like i've never
seen that if you know you know
i've never seen it but when you just
said it there i can suss it
kind of quick but yeah there's some that
just
no idea is it it's the ones that get me
like the goat one there's the ones that
get me that look like they could be
something else
okay like in my opinion got me only for
like five minutes yeah when the first
time i seen it imo
because that looks like it could be like
emo or something like that yeah i know
what you mean because it's
like an action yeah when it actually
looks like it could be a word or a new
turn or phrase
that's when they stumped me when i'm
like i don't get it
um and uh yeah bro that wasn't [ __ ]
annoying
that was a [ __ ] annoying like google
it in it i don't know exactly exactly
the point trying to make google it
google it
don't ask me what ravenous means because
[ __ ] google it
do you not understand that you're the
idiot in no offense you're the idiot
here
don't make it worse on yourself that's
embarrassing
that reminds me of the yeah that you
were talking to that time
um this thing
from time ago yeah yeah yeah sainsbury's
tesco yeah
yeah have you told the story on here i
don't know
i know you've told banging her on here
because you said united quick and you
tried to stop and our ass was just
fat flooding that was fat
it felt so fat this was such a long time
ago
bro what was it you said what was your
like aspiration yes i was like what do
you want to do and stuff oh
we were messaging back and forth this
was when i was still living in london
and she was like oh no sign easy i want
to work in sainsbury's or tesco's
i looked at my phone like what i
screenshotted i sent it to you
i remember putting a group chat straight
away
i was thinking she was an idiot but
don't get me wrong like there is nothing
there's nothing wrong there's nothing
wrong there's nothing there's nothing
wrong in the slightest there's nothing
wrong but if i ask you what are your
aspirations in life
and you give me that i feel so bad for
[ __ ] i feel like i shouldn't have even
[ __ ] you
do you know what i mean because there's
no way we're gonna say sorry this is not
okay
carry on go go go have to say it now you
have to say it now
you have to say it now we're here for it
shits and gigs you have to say it now
i was just saying like obviously when
you said like
feel bad for [ __ ] you like you feel
like you're taking advantage of like a
disabled person
do you know what i mean do you know
exactly do you know what i mean though
i know i'm thinking like does she not
realize she can pat and that's just when
laughs
that's why i said i shouldn't even say i
might have to edit out but you know when
you said i feel bad for even [ __ ] you
yeah you feel like she's not aware of
what's going she's not like i would
maybe
like you do know you can get a job there
today if you get one her bubble is so
small
her bubble is slow are you amish like
where are you from
your aspiration how old was she she was
on me
she's older than me and this was post
uni as well
posters so this was probably
12 or 13 2000 because this was post
deloitte as well grill on the market
because i remember you were going
grilling them like you weren't underway
anymore
i can tell you that okay i know it's
going to make you i didn't know about
the law yeah yeah yeah and she was older
than you she was older than me so she
was mid-20s
yeah she was she was good 20s yeah and
her aspirations to work in tesco
tesco's when she said that i
couldn't i i felt like i
wanted to reverse the sex kind of this
is after you [ __ ] up i think so
i don't remember the things i don't
remember but knowing me it was probably
before
because it must have been before because
i was still talking to her
does that make sense it has to have been
before because i'm still talking to her
because i still wanted to nut so it must
have been before it must have been
before because our ass was so fat
oh and i think the reason because prior
to
like apart from my latest stage of years
now back then i never used to move to
girls
um i was just about to say before you
even said that i was just about to say
i remember you telling me the story of
how you met her and thinking you
absolute beast would you mean you just
turn someone on
road because i never used to move to
girls
so i'll say the story the because i've
already spoken about the get off me
before
yeah and this is the same chick so i i
call her shoreditch [ __ ] because i was
on my way to shoreditch yeah yeah
to meet my friend for food yeah i think
i got off i had to change somewhere so
maybe i've got off i like hot stuff or
something i can't remember
so i got off the train i was walking
one way we walking she was walking the
opposite way we crossed paths
i saw me see her she wasn't
it was one of them was i knew she had a
back from the front i knew she had a
back from the front
so when i turned round she turned around
as well
but the first thing i saw was the back
and then i saw her see me then when i
went back to
talk to her she wasn't as buff as as
anything but the back was so big
yeah i think that was where the
confidence came from because i was there
already i couldn't i couldn't back out
yeah yeah so i had to patent it somehow
i don't know what i said but we
exchanged numbers
yeah and we kept on moving okay funny
thing is she rang me and she said she
wanted to meet me that day
something like that or the next day it
was so weird it was so maybe because put
me off immediately
it it was it was so weird i thought she
ever called me she bailed me or messaged
me
whilst i was at the lunch time when i
said i went to meet my friend
i was like what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
but i gave her the benefit of the duck
yeah because her arse was so
fat it was disgracefully fine and it
makes sense to why i knighted so early
because when she sat on it james
ah this one i didn't [ __ ] up probably
about maybe a month after we
exchanged the numbers or whatever maybe
a couple weeks i remember it was on my i
had a two-hour break from work
and she lived and i think i i worked in
central london i think she lived in like
south south south i took a train there
smashed i didn't eat i didn't eat during
my break
you're a trooper for sex sometimes dude
that's something i will
never do i know and i'm jealous that you
could do it like it's not something i'm
proud of
lazy bro fam i'm never doing that
never doing it and i think it's people
think i hate sex the way i act sometimes
i'm just not willing to do anything for
it i am i am of course i am
of course i am but to an extent yeah
like if someone said
like you have to i don't know like my
mind works two different ways like if
someone
said right you've got a two hour lunch
break like if someone patted it for me
like you've got two hour lunch break
you need to get this train this time she
knows i've got only got two hour lunch
break she's like right
do this do this [ __ ] me and bounce if if
i've got the whole thing blueprint
in my mind everyone knows what's going
on then it's plausible then it's
plausible
but if i'm working off my own brain
thinking right she lives here
i've got two hour break i can probably
squeeze it in it i'll get flustered yeah
i'll get flustered and i'm like
[ __ ] all of that [ __ ] this but the
reason why i did that was because
i knew for a fact there was nowhere i
was using my day off to go with linker
so i had to patent it where i was
already closer to her than normal yeah
because i live in
oh i lived in east she she lives in
south i don't know where she is in her
life now to be honest yeah yeah
um but i was closer to her from work
yeah so i was like
this is the best opportunity this is the
best opportunity and i'm not going to
[ __ ] it up
yeah considering i knew i mean and i
already said obviously i didn't move to
girls back then yeah considering i moved
to her and it was patterned yeah yeah
yeah and she was eager to see me anyway
because she was messaging me or whatever
yeah yeah yeah
i was like i have to do it i have to
find a way fair play i have to find a
way
so what happened when you got you just
immediately no no obviously not no
um i think because it was one of the
ones where she only rented a room in the
spot it wasn't her gas
oh snap was one of them one so she i
think she gave me like a quick tour
whatever we got to a room
i think we were chilling talking talking
whatever and then we just got down to
business i can't remember like the
semantics
yeah because it was such a long time ago
yeah
but she sat on it at night and i left
long story short long story short ah
it sounds like a good nut it was a deep
nut i bet oh it was a scary thing
ah bro yeah for real right question yeah
before we do what might they ask i've
got a question yeah on the scale because
someone asked me recently
would i be comfortable with my
girlfriend
doing only fans okay and i was like yeah
okay this is me personally okay i'm not
expecting every guy to have that answer
i expect most guys to not have the
answer but for me personally i was like
yeah
i don't care because
obviously people probably know right now
i i'm very
as much as i talk about my insecurities
and stuff like that i'm very secure when
it comes to
my partners and not necessarily
secure it's just that if you're going to
cheat you're going to cheat
okay if you don't want to be with me you
don't want to be with me yeah if you
want to like cheat and lie to me
you're going to do what you want to do
regardless of what ever happens
so just [ __ ] do it so i don't ever
i'm never the type of guy that's like
i don't want to go in on girls holidays
i don't want to doing this i'm not
trying to
mitigate the options for her to cheat on
me okay
yeah i wanted to be open just free if
you're gonna do it and do it
i'm not trying to limit your
opportunities to do it yeah for my own
sanity if you're gonna do it [ __ ] do
it
and um like the person who asked me was
a girl
and i was like yeah i'm not insecure
like it doesn't bother me because like
for starters if my girl's gonna cheat on
me
i'm sure the last person she's going to
cheat on me is one of the sleaze bags
that are paying to see her nudes
you know what i mean yeah yeah if she's
going to [ __ ] someone she's not going to
be [ __ ] a [ __ ] only fans guy
for one that's just the cheating aspect
yeah yeah and as far as
me feeling a way about naked or
semi-naked or
like she put post provocative posts on
her only fans page
like again that doesn't really bother me
i don't know why it just doesn't really
bother me it's just like
if it's empowering for her or whatever
she wants to do just like
just do it like yeah it really doesn't
bother me it
i i don't know why like visible for you
yes and no i feel like i get where
you're coming from in a sense that
because
if she's doing it she's doing it for
herself like she did maybe she's doing
it for people she's doing it for herself
whatever
but within the same breath
you've that's probably not necessarily
how you met her but
when you first met or how when you first
started talking
in your eyes she was provocative anyway
yeah does that make sense that's exactly
so why
should she now i would have been
attracted to that side of that side of
her regardless if she had already fans
at the time
yeah i would have been attracted to yeah
her provocative nature so why does she
now have to change that because
you guys are together exactly yeah i
spoke to the bear people who talk about
like they get vex like they meet a girl
she could be wearing all sorts and then
we've probably spoke about them here
before
probably and that once they're together
they want them dressed up in [ __ ]
curtains cousins i don't want
doesn't make sense um and again like if
people if i'm walking down the street
with my girl a matter of
watching her it's a compliment to me
gasps yes i always get discussed
because i do the same [ __ ] thing to
when i see a guy walking with a girl
with a banging girl i'm like [ __ ] round
of applause you secured it
you secured a tang if my body's banging
as well
i'm vexed i'm not vex but i'm just like
mate
how i want to do those buddhism kudos i
want to spike one of them once i'm like
gang you've [ __ ] done a thing
yeah i'm not thinking he must be feeling
insecure right now because this girl's
out here looking buff
i'm not thinking that i'm thinking this
this guy's got the game sussed he's
going unlocked he's got a pattern
he's going to hold the whole time he's
patting the game and i'm rating him more
than i'm writing her
i think i look at her i think she's
banging i rate him immediately i don't
even think anything more about her
i'm rating him that's it so when if i'm
with a girl and man are watching me like
that
my phone's [ __ ] blowing up i should
have turned the [ __ ] off um
yeah then yeah like
i've lost my train of thought now [ __ ]
sake i know you mean though yeah anyway
that's what you mean as well
the the the scale i had so for me
obviously i don't have
a problem date with a girl who hasn't
only fans page so
i was thinking from only fans to full-on
sex worker
where's the scale okay of like you're
just not
you're not even willing to compromise
with this this is not happening here
yeah yeah so from starting from
got an only fans page to full-on
prostitute
and then in the middle we've got like
stripper
um escort but never fox like dame kind
of things for you
when is it like no is it from straight
from only fans or does it go all the way
up to no no it's not it's not reaching
that that spectrum at all i think
early fans is is already
enough but if she's
if i didn't know she would like let's
say you slightly talk because i don't
think she would tell me she's a stripper
off the bat
do you know what i mean i don't think
strippers just say oh i'm a stripper
obviously they'll say they're a dancer
whatever
but more time if they're a stripper
they've got another job anyway because
you only strip at night you don't strip
during the day so yeah they will
probably tell me what they do
during the day or whatever their normal
nine to five or whatever it is
so if she tells me she's got only fans
and i'm attracted to her regardless of
all that
stuff i think the cut-off point would be
i think nothing past stripper yeah
nothing partial it would i think it
would
i would be i think i'll be gassed at
first knowing she's a stripper because i
know that sex would pop
i know the sex sound like anything in a
boudoir would pop she'll be
down for all sorts that would attract me
the sex i had with that one stripper one
time was [ __ ] unbelievable let me
just put that in there i bet
yeah i've never [ __ ] a stripper so it
was fantastic i bet
um so anything beyond that i think is a
would be a bit too much i think it would
get to a stage where if
we i start to develop feelings for the
girl and she's still stripping
i don't know whether i'd be okay with
[ __ ] her and seeing other guys just
like other guys just seeing her naked
like that yeah yeah so the only fast
thing for me
is khan because she's never gonna she
just wants their money
from all the fans that's all she wants
she doesn't want anything else from you
buy your money
yes she enjoys it it empowers her kudos
to you as long as it's bringing up and
bring you happiness
that's fine by me yes so i think that
for me is calm yeah but the strip and
saying if i'm just [ __ ] her
if i'm just seeing enough it's just fun
i'm fine with that but if i develop
feelings for her
i wouldn't want to tell her to change
because that's her i might more myself
bounce
because it's not fair for me to tell her
to change who she is for me
unless she's unless we have a sit-down
conversation
she's feeling me as much as i'm feeling
her yeah and we discuss things and she's
like oh maybe i should
and then that's the only way because i
wouldn't want to i'm not the type of
person to tell you to do something that
you're not comfortable with
yeah rags so that that's where i think
about it rags fair play more about
yourself
where's that where do you lie in the
spectrum i don't know
i feel like i would be fine
obviously i said only fan's fine
stripper i think i'll be fine
[Music]
but you're right in terms of when it
comes to like the feelings and stuff
like that like dating someone that i
don't have that much feelings for
i can take it quite far quite far i
don't like i'd probably date a porn star
and be fine with it yeah right um but
yeah i think
no feelings i'll go all the way up to
porn star
um i'd probably love it yeah
because you know everything's gonna bang
everything she's down for anything
no no strong feelings i'll go all the
way up to porn star
i'm never obviously gonna date a [ __ ]
prostitute yeah um
but then again because sometimes you
have those high-class prostitutes i
don't really [ __ ] that many guys
and they get paid but then again i still
don't think i don't think that one would
bang for me
maybe porn star would probably as far as
i could go with no feelings porn stars
as far as i could go
what you want to do is bang her that's
all you'd want to do
that's all you'd want to do yes yes god
yes god yes
um so yeah porn star is where i'd go no
feelings but like if i'm in love with
this girl
i'd like to think if i was another i
could still firm the strip in
okay but i don't know i'm gonna tell you
now i don't think i confirm it
as long as we if i especially if i've
got more feelings than her i'd have to
leave
because i couldn't i i may broach the
topic and if she still wants to do it
then i i can't tell her i can't tell her
to change
yeah that's how i met her yeah yeah you
know i mean that's so unfair thanks
i was going to ask before we do our
maddie also ladies please either comment
or whatever
when you watch porn do you concentrate
on the guy or do you concentrate on the
girl
because i concentrate on the girl
obviously of course
but i i've never known what the girls
concentrate on especially if you're
bisexual what do you concentrate on as
well
i think that's a great that's a great i
just feel like everyone concentrates on
the girl
do you know i feel like that too that
being said that being said do you know
when um
tiger king came out yes and the way he
patterned his new husband
the young guy the tall brother yeah the
one that killed himself yes
the when he asked him like are you
straight or gay unless i'm straight
a man said when you watch porn do you
like guys with a small dick or a big
dick to [ __ ] the girl and he's like
obviously big dick
and he's like you're not that straight
then no homo
i get it i get it
no no small dicting fam no
it's not something i want to say but i
never watch porn
when the guy's wearing a condom neither
do i
i think neither do i never fum
spot me quick quick firm thumb
if i watch i'm losing it if i see in the
thumbnail
a little satin a little see the little
sheet thing there
skipping i'm not even clicking it
skipping
i'm not even clicking it why is that i
don't know
because i feel like i feel like maybe
our brains are wired to that
when you watch porn you feel like you're
there you feel like you're do you know i
mean you feel like you're engulfed in it
yeah that's why when you wank it feels
the same
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and obviously
we we hate condoms it's we've said it's
a test
so that's probably the reason
it could be different for everyone it
probably is different for everyone
but i just can't watch porn with a guy
wearing a card it makes no sense to me
it's dead it makes no sense to me the
worst it's not like i'm not there i'm
not doing anything
because i know what it feels like and i
know i'm not getting excited
it's crazy but yeah get ladies what do
you guys concentrate on
when you watch porn do you concentrate
on the guy do you concentrate on the
girl you concentrate on both if you're
bisexual as well
i'm very intrigued to know what you
concentrate on if you're bisexual
like if you're male and you're bisexual
if you're female you're bisexual i'm so
intrigued i'm intrigued as well because
i watched that uh that 365 days filming
about i need to watch that i've heard
i've heard this it's crud i've just
heard it's sexual tension
and the way we like to [ __ ] girls is how
we [ __ ] girls
a watcher this week spoiler alert i'm
just going to have to say it yes
that's fine that's fine it ties in well
with when you said what do they look at
yeah because there's bits in there
where like you can tell that what
i'm sorry my phone's [ __ ] blowing up
what's going on
um you can tell you can tell
that the girl is down to see my man
get pleasured okay like it turns her on
the way we said
like going down on a girl to make like
for me making a goal come is the most
yes the best thing in the world it's the
best possible thing yeah yeah yeah
it turns me on there's nothing more that
turns my other thing yeah make it a go
come on
that's why i mean pretty much every time
for those
so um
in that it's like the same thing because
there's
one scene so basically the premise of
the film is that
my man is in love with this woman right
yeah um
i wouldn't give too much backstory as to
why whatever but he's in love with this
woman he sees her
and just basically kidnaps her he's
[ __ ] rich he's like a
like a drug lord slash like he owns like
clubs and stuff like that he's
he's like a like a mob guy kind of like
okay he's italian and she's polish
okay so they speak in english because
obviously they've got two different
languages
okay um and he basically kidnaps her and
said you're gonna stay here
in my yard for 365 days you've got that
amount of time to fall in love with me
if you don't fall in love with me in the
next year you're afraid to go
but you've got that amount of time to
fall in love with me and let's see how
it goes let's see what happens all right
and he says i won't rape you
like um don't
like like if you say no i'm not gonna do
anything just to let you know yeah
fam but he pushes that to the [ __ ]
line
he pushes it to the [ __ ] line fam and
one
time she's getting mouthy with him
mouthy with him i think she teases him
or something
and then he gets vex so my man chains
her to his bed
chains her to his bed and then man says
i'm gonna make sure and he's
buff by the way buffy's white guy have
seen
he's barf cuz he's a solid six
three six four stacks is he stacked he's
but he's athletic
i've seen it we'll be like yes he is and
the man that i've seen it'll be like
loki yes he [ __ ] is the buffest white
guy i've seen
anyway yeah yeah and um
and she's biff as well she's [ __ ] pif
but she's like a basic she's like
she's got no outstanding features but
she's just gorgeous
normally she's just normal gorgeous yeah
and she's got sex appeal yeah you're
gonna love this the story's so
[ __ ] but i love the storyline but it's
[ __ ] important is that the best
storyline pawn you've seen okay and
basically man said
all right cool all right cool you're
gonna play with me safe i'm gonna change
to the bed
and i'm gonna make you watch what you're
missing out on
he brings in one other yeah sits on a
sofa
and i thought he's gonna plow this over
yeah so i'm thinking
oh he's gonna bang the [ __ ] out of this
new girl
so she knows what she could be getting
right now now cause
this other guy sucks him off
he just sits there and gets sucked off
she goes for it it's explicit cuz
jesus gagging on it i need to suck some
nuts in her mouth and the girl in the
bed is writhing
she's sweating sweating
sweating and i was like oh
she's down to see my man bust nuts she's
gas watching him
feel good that's gas that's some sex
it's the sexiest film going
it's the sexiest film going
i need to watch it you do i need to
storyline trash
apparently there's another movie because
i saw it on tick tock there's another
movie i think it's called love or
something like that
if you watch if they said if you've seen
365 days watch love
and the first opening scene i think it's
called love don't quote me on that
the first opening scene will make you
gasp
i've not seen the movie obviously but
i've seen the reactions on tick tock of
so many different people
as soon as it starts every man's jaw
drops
and i want to know where it is because
it's similar gang it's similar
so love is similar to 365 so i just
saying it's because you've seen 365
watch that
that's what i've seen cool right bro i
actually have to go
i have to go we'll do double the amount
of the [ __ ] next time that's fine
i have to go that's fine that was a
different episode guys next week i'll
see you next week